my opinion on the question of role
models is yes i have lived in the region
for for a year when i was younger in
the--wait and now live in turkey in
easton responsible for Middle East
Africa for company I had a wonderful
example of role models actually coming
into the store yesterday as i was in a
queue next to a young Afghan lady after
what she did and she told me she was an
elected member of Afghanistan's grounds
and I said what do you think you made
the achievement as being and she told me
being a member as a woman of
Afghanistan's fun I think role models
can play a very very important
for the younger generation look up
naturally to entrepreneurs to gender
diversity and ask questions based on
framework of the older generation as
laid around them I think it's important
that it leads us to evolve into a
dynamic wiper motor for the world it
must have role models that break some of
the frameworks and rocket systems that
are in place already its natural state
for any part of the world but I think
one which is a particularly important
for the future of the Middle